wie fasst man so ein jahr zusammen
ich weiß es nicht wir machen jetzt zum
dritten mal den jahresrückblick für die
wissenschaft aber dieses jahr ist
irgendwie anders egal
wisst ihr was ich bin trotzdem
optimistisch denn so schlimm schrecklich
verrückt komisch lang und irgendwie
gleichzeitig auch kurz 2020 auch war es
sind auch eine menge guter dinge
passiert corona hat verändert wie
wissenschaftler untereinander
kommunizieren bereits anfang januar
hatten wir die komplette er in agno
sequenz des virus und haben sie für alle
zugänglich ins internet gestellt nur
drei tage später wurde das erste
nachweisverfahren für das virus hier in
deutschland entwickelt und auch weltweit
zur verfügung gestellt und noch im
selben jahr wurde der erste impfstoff
zugelassen
das ist nicht nur der am schnellsten
entwickelte impfstoff der geschichte es
ist auch der erste seiner art
normalerweise dort ist um die zehn jahre
einen impfstoff zu entwickeln und es
können sogar mehrere jahrzehnte sein der
bisher am schnellsten entwickelt
impfstoff war ein verbesserter für 1967
und das dauerte vier jahre
und trotzdem hatte die sicherheit für
die korona impfstoffe immer priorität
ich finde das sollte man immer dazu
sagen weil es viele leute gibt die noch
angst vor den neuen impfstoffen haben
aber es wurden keine kritischen
abkürzungen genommen um so schnell zu
einem impfstoff zu gelangen
stattdessen wurden klinische studien
phasen parallel durchgeführt
bürokratische prozesse entschlackt und
impfdosen auf risiko bereits vor der
zulassung produziert alles geht auf
einmal viel schneller wenn wir alle an
einem strang ziehen gelder sind
plötzlich da die bürokratie wird auf ein
minimum beschränkt das ist nur schade
dass es einen globalen notstand braucht
damit wir das erleben
aber natürlich ist 2020 nicht nur corona
passiert also ich hab mal wieder die
wissenschaftler
wissenschaftsjournalisten und science
youtuber gefragt mit denen ich dieses
jahr am meisten zu tun hatte was in
ihren augen das wichtigste ereignis in
der wissenschaft des jahres 2020 war es
sind also persönliche antworten und
dieses video hier ist vor allem keine
vollständige liste aller ereignisse des
jahres
ach ja und was mich persönlich besonders
überrascht hat ist das auch meine
kollegen optimistisch waren das
wichtigste ereignis kann sowohl etwas
positives als auch etwas negatives sein
aber fast alle sprechen über positive
ereignisse und das gibt mir ein bisschen
hoffnung also ohne euch zu lange auf die
folter zu spannen das hier sind ihre
antworten
hey klaus hier vom kanal tool und mein
persönliches highlight ist dieser
bericht hier co2 neutral bis 2035 vom
wuppertal institut wie viel co2 neutral
werden können in deutschland das wissen
wir eigentlich schon lange da gibt's
1000 studien zu das alles nichts neues
nur meistens beziehen sich diese studien
auf das jahr 2050 weil das so unser
offizielles politisches ziel jahr ist
wir wissen aber wenn wir weiter so viel
co2 ausstoßen wie bisher dann ist 2050
viel zu spät wir müssen viel früher co2
neutral werden und deshalb freue ich
mich so sehr über diesen bericht von
einem der renommiertesten
forschungsinstitute in dem bereich der
deutlich zeigt wir können das eben auch
schon 2035 schaffen die maßnahmen die da
drin stehen das sind auch eigentlich
keine neuen sachen so das sind genau die
dinge die zu erwarten werden keine
großen überraschungen
der fokus liegt er darauf dass technisch
nichts dagegen spricht die früher zu
schaffen
trotzdem ist es natürlich
gesellschaftlich und politischen
herausforderungen und muss in dem
bereich nach oberste priorität haben
damit das klappt aber auch das ist ja
machbar
ich glaube die letzten jahre haben
deutlich gezeigt was gesellschaftlicher
druck so bringen kann
und auch das im grunde die zeit für
ausreden so langsam vorbei ist hey ich
bin die marlene vom kanal doktor ist und
mein wissenschaftsrat 2020 ist eine von
google geschaffene ki die kürzlich eines
der größten wissenschaftlichen probleme
gelöst hat die google steht meint zeigte
in den vergangenen jahren immer wieder
wie gut ki in brettspielen wie schach
oder go oder dem computerspiel star auf
zwei den menschen inzwischen überlegen
ist
einen wirklichen praktischen nutzen
hatte diese spielerei zwar nicht die
firma legte damit aber den grundstein
für ihre software verfolgt
ab sofort kann mit überraschender
genauigkeit die proteinfaltung
voraussagen darunter versteht man den
prozess durch den proteine ihre
dreidimensionale struktur erhalten
wissenschaftler suchen schon seit
jahrzehnten nach einer möglichkeit
anhand der abfolge von aminosäuren aus
denen die proteine bestehen
eine vorhersage über ihre endgültige
form zu treffen
diese struktur kann zwar auf
verschiedene arten experimentell
ermittelt werden das ist aber sehr
zeitaufwendig und damit auch ziemlich
teuer
somit stellt die turbo methode von
haverford einen echten
wissenschaftlichen durchbruch dar
es wird spannend zu sehen wie googles ki
in zukunft die menschheit voranbringen
wird für mich fach 2020 einfach sehr
interessant dass man gesehen hat was ein
krasses defizit wir bei online
unterricht haben das sage ich nicht nur
so dass studien zu zum beispiel eine
forsa umfrage im auftrag vom verband für
bildung und erziehung die gezeigt hat
dass 40 prozent der schulleitungen sagen
dass ihre schülerinnen und schüler ab
die schulen technisch nicht gut genug
ausgestattet sind es gab hier das
deutsche bildungsbarometer was zum einen
genau das gleiche gezeigt dass aber halt
auch noch als grund angeführt hat was
lehren der wahl gesagt haben dass sie
nicht gut genug ausgebildet sind für
digitalen unterricht und ich selber ich
forscher in dem bereich bin in einer
arbeitsgruppe drin die halbjahr
erklärvideos erforscht und dass ich da
krass fand das mir einen professoren
gesagt hat mehr youtube da kann man ja
gar nichts lernen und das hat mich sehr
geärgert ich hatte so ein bisschen die
hoffnung dass 2020 gezeigt hat dass man
doch was auf youtube lernen kann und ich
finde doktor watson ist die super beweis
dafür
deswegen würde ich sagen war das thema
digitale bildung für mich 2020 dass mein
name ist folgt verstecken und professor
für regenerative energiesysteme an der
htw berlin
was ist mein wissenschaftliches
highlight dieses jahres in abu dhabi
erhielt eine photovoltaikanlage bei
einer ausschreibung den zuschlag die
strom für 13 5 us cent pro
kilowattstunde liefern soll und
unterbietet damit locker kohle gas und
atomkraft werke um größen offen viele
stellen sich die frage was hat das mit
wissenschaft zu tun um die klimakrise
gerade in vertretbaren grenzen noch zu
halten müssen wir bis 2040 weltweit
klimaneutral werden
das kann nur gelingen wenn klimaschutz
auch weltweit zu bezahlbaren preisen
verfügbar ist und es ist der erfolg der
solarforschung der letzten jahrzehnte
das solarenergie jetzt die mit abstand
preiswerteste art der stromerzeugung ist
wir müssen nun nicht mehr auf die
erfindung irgendeiner rockets 1 macht
die politik muss nur noch rasch die
bremsen beim ausbau erneuerbarer
energien lösen und die forschung wird
dann ihren beitrag dazu leisten dass wir
weltweit eine klimaneutrale sichere und
bezahlbare energieversorgung bis 2040
auch wirklich realisiert bekommt
ich mache es angeschrieben und mainz ein
zeile das ist ja ein link und beziehungs
also die neweling vorstellung von elenas
denn das was der damit seiner filme
macht ist irgendwie straight aus dem
science-fiction-film yu ling bao nämlich
ein chip der in dein gehirn eingepflanzt
wird mit dem wir nicht nur gehirnströme
auslesen können soll sondern auch
steuern können soll dass die ersten
prototypen seiner chips schock
funktionieren hat in dem eindrucksvollen
in seiner schweinchen gezeigt in der
nicht nur gezeigt hat dass man den chip
auch wieder entfernen kann und der
organismus trotzdem noch ohne probleme
überlebt sondern auch dass der chip
lange zeit in einem schweins gehirn
keine schäden verursacht und mit dem
testwagen sogar eine lage die
beinbewegungen des schweines
vorherzusagen elenas planen diesem
projekt zahlreiche gehirn krankheiten
heilen zu können was einen riesigen
fortschritt in der medizin entwickelt er
ein eigenes chirurgie roboter der diesen
chip einpflanzen soll dann gesagt dass
ich wieder mitmachen durfte bis nächstes
jahr
ich bin an tivo ist direktorin des
alfred wegener institut teils zentrum
für polar und meeresforschung das
wichtige ereignis in unserer forschungen
20 20 war für mich das gelingen der
großen internationalen nordpolexpedition
mosaik auf unserem forschungseisbrecher
polarstern die korona panini hat ja
weltweit den betrieb von expeditionen
lahmgelegt wird schlimmen auswirkungen
auf unsere fähigkeit natur und umwelt zu
beobachten und zu schützen
in zeiten des schnellen wandels aber zu
wissen das team ist nun heil und gesund
zurückgekommen mit einem riesigen schatz
an daten und wissen über den kaum
erforschten arktischen winter diese
unglaubliche dynamik das schnelle
schmelzen im sommer dass die gesehen
haben und die sind jetzt da das ist für
mich das größte
auch zu erleben wie dabei die
partnerschaft mit medien und
kommunikatoren dazu geführt hat dass die
wissenschaft und die polare natur eine
stimme bekommen hat angekommen ist in
unseren wohnzimmern auf küchentischen in
den mobiltelefon und vor allen dingen in
den köpfen art von unseren kindern das
macht einfach freude sich faktisch um
kanals taktisch und dieses jahr haben
zwei forscherinnen den chemie nobelpreis
verliehen bekommt und zwar für die
erforschung von methoden zur
erbgutveränderungen mit der gen scherrer
christfest nein und ich finde das extrem
wichtig denn ich habe durch unter
anderem fed rix video dazu letztes jahr
eine faszination dafür entwickelt das
ist in unserer generation noch möglich
sein könnte das altern weg zu forschen
und durch christa bin ich immer
optimistischer geworden dass das
tatsächlich noch in unserer generation
möglich wäre und wenn es dafür dass
jetzt auch noch einen nobelpreis gibt
leute das ist cool es wird in diese
richtung geforscht und ich kann euch
auch nur raten studiert irgendetwas in
richtung biologie wir sind nicht aus dem
rheinland man kennt uns vielleicht eher
als methodisch incorrect mit podcast
streams wir betreiben
wissenschaftskommunikation wir sind
physiker und was hat dieses jahr die
menschheit und auch uns als
wissenschaftler beschäftigt cupid 19 und
wenn man unsere alten folgen mal hört
von unserem podcast sieht man wir lagen
ordentlich daneben also wir haben uns
auch ordentlich vertan als wir versucht
haben diese pandemie am anfang des
jahres einzuschätzen
aber das schöne ist ja als
wissenschaftler mit wissenschaftlicher
methodik beurteilt meine lage möglichst
nach fakten und passt seine meinung oder
seiner einschätzung auch an und genau
das haben wir auch getan und das auch so
kommuniziert und was er noch etwas hat
man gelernt dieses jahr nämlich wie
leistungsfähig die wissenschaft ist
extrem viele studien kam weltweit raus
die versucht haben zu verstehen wie
tickt dieser virus wie steckt man sich
an wie können wir uns am besten schützen
und nicht zuletzt deswegen sind wir
eigentlich ganz gut durch die erste
welle gekommen mit mit wenig infizierten
und noch etwas hat sich gezeigt wie
wichtig grundlagenforschung ist denn wir
haben jetzt am ende des jahres schon
mehrere impfstoffe
wir haben medikamente die haben wir nur
weil einfach schon jahrzehntelang an
ähnlichen
ihren geforscht wurde und da sieht man
wie wichtig grundlagenforschung ist
wissenschaft vordringen wie schon gesagt
habe dass sie es keine vollständige
liste sind ein paar der highlights die
für uns 2020 wichtig waren
deswegen ist das video auch noch nicht
vorbei ich würde gerne wissen was für
euch 2020 das wichtigste ereignis in der
wissenschaft war die wissenschaft
jahresrückblicke sind videos bei denen
es wie ich finde sich immer besonders
lohnt in die kommentare zu schauen denn
da entdeckt man noch mal ganz viele
weitere wichtige coole erschreckende und
beeindruckende dinge die man vielleicht
selber verpasst oder auch schon wieder
vergessen hat also das gold mal durch
die kommentare neigt die comments denen
ihr zustimmt und diskutiert mit uns
zusammen wie war das wissenschaftsjahr
2020 ich möchte mir außerdem mal eine
minute zeit nehmen um danke zu sagen an
erster stelle dem team hinter doktor
watson wir sind 2020 von fünf auf neun
leute gewachsen die diese videos hier
unseren instagram channel videos auf
anderen kanälen und auch so so vieles
mehr möglich machen
manu marie an jonas maria jakob caro
hannes danke für eure arbeit die ihr
dieses jahr gemacht habe sowohl im büro
als auch zu hause
danke dass ihr alles gibt um unsere
zuschauer ein bisschen schlauer zu
machen ohne euch wäre doktor watson
wahrscheinlich noch der kanal die nicht
2015 gegründet habe und nicht das was es
heute geworden ist außerdem möchte ich
mich bei allen bedanken die mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben
freelancer andere firmen auftraggeber
danke für euer vertrauen und die
wunderbare zusammenarbeit die dieses
jahr zu vielen coolen projekten geführt
hat
danke auch an die vielen youtuber mit
denen wir dieses jahr vor und behind the
scenes zusammengearbeitet haben und
danke an alle wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die uns dieses jahr
interviews gegeben haben oder für fragen
zur verfügung standen
und natürlich möchte ich mich bei euch
bedanken danke dafür dass ihr unsere
videos gucken danke dass ihr so viele
kommentare schreibt uns mit video ideen
konstruktiver kritik und einfach nur
lustigen witzen unterstützt und
besonderen dank natürlich an alle
patrons durch euren support konnten wir
dieses jahr ein paar coole videos machen
die ohne euch einfach nicht möglich
gewesen wären
das gleiche gilt ab nächstem jahr dann
auch für alle neuen abonnenten auf
doktor watson tv und damit sind wir
schon beim nächsten jahr
ich hoffe dass 2021 ein besseres jahr
wird als 2020 wir sind noch lange nicht
mit der pandemie durch
aber es gibt ein licht am ende des
tunnels wir sind auf jeden fall da um
für euch weiter videos zu machen und
werden schon eine menge ideen für videos
für serien für kollaborationen mit
anderen youtube und sogar für komplett
neue youtube-kanäle wir haben auf jeden
fall bock auf 2.021 und wir danken euch
dafür dass ihr aus 2020 das beste
gemacht habt wir sehen uns nächstes jahr
macht gut bleibt gesund bleibt neugierig